[Music]
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
super-excited to talk about brain
computer interfaces democratised we have
Connor Roose Amano joining us on the
show hello Thank You Alan it's great to
be here thanks so much for coming on I'm
super excited huge congrats on all the
progress you've made with open BCI the
video that we just watched was so cool
we're even young kids are now being able
to control things like these robotic
arms with their brainwaves that's so so
so cool for those who don't know Connors
background he's co-founder and CEO of
open BCI which produces and sells
open-source brain computer interfaces
he's also research affiliate at MIT
Media Lab and you can find the links in
the bio below open BCI comm as well as
their Twitter open BCI Connor let's
start things off with one of our
favorite questions ask our guests what
are your thoughts on the direction of
our world thoughts on the direction of
our world well I I think that humanity
is pretty cool
I think that we do some amazing things
but I also think that we are you know
we're also vulnerable to ourselves so
you know we need to as we build things
like brain computer interfaces and
technology that are you know where the
implications are great and and somewhat
of a double-edged sword we have to be
very smart about staking out the
scenarios that we don't want to end up
in and designing around them so that's
kind of you know a lot of the impetus of
what we do is just making sure that
brain computer interfaces are brought
into the world in a in a way that is
beneficial to humanity and not
detrimental so yeah so so out of all the
future cases of potential trajectories
of civilization it's like staking out
the ones
that are negative and making sure double
triple quadruple checking to make sure
that we're not going to they'll devaron
to those that's a it's a great way to
put it
okay let's talk about the journey born
in new jersey grew up into virginia
ended up going to Parsons in Columbia so
teach us about who you were as a kid and
what got you interested in science and
technology
as a kid I always really loved art I
always loved drawing and building little
things with my hands I actually didn't
get into computer science or electronics
until grad school but I always you know
I loved painting little models and and
things like that and and always loved
pencil drawing and then you know in high
school I went to a science and tech high
school that was very focused on math
science engineering you know and then
ended up going to Columbia to study
civil engineering but when I was there I
discovered like 3d modeling and design
and you know that kind of took me
throughout college I realized that I
really loved design and I love art and I
had to like be in a dry you know
engineering degree where I was like
learning about digging holes in the
ground to like realize okay like I need
I need a little bit more creativity and
art in my life you know later on I
realized that digging holes in the
ground is very important you know like
at the core of any masterful tool or
beautiful you know usable scalable
product is a foundation like you really
need foundational thinking and
foundational design to to build
something that's scalable so I think
later on I started to appreciate my
civil engineering degree in like the
value of digging a hole in the ground
it's such a valuable piece of your the
component to what you're now able to do
with that engineering background yeah
yeah and also art I wanna I want you to
teach us about the story of also what
triggered you to pursue this which was
the rug the Indian
they had playing rugby right so yeah you
all touch on childhood again my my
nickname as a kid was a kamikaze Connor
so I was like pretty fearless and you
know would pretty much just run into
walls and like see like alright so the
wall is stronger than I am
okay good noted but that you know I
really loved contact sports so in high
school I played football and then I was
recruited to Columbia to play college
football I ended up switching over to
rugby but you know like sports that you
know require you to run into heavy
objects quickly and over the course of
like four or five years I sustained a
number of pretty serious concussions
which you know started to take you know
started to take its toll on me both
physically and mentally
so by senior year of college I was you
know pretty depressed I was having
trouble focusing in school you know
somewhat bipolar in the sense that like
I would go from you know manic highs to
lows and so that was actually the first
time that I really started getting
interested in the brain it was like
somewhat of a selfish thing because I
was like hey what's going on here I yeah
I damaged the hardware and the software
I feel the effect like I feel my ability
to like my lack of ability to think the
way that I used to and so that was the
first time I really started getting
introspective about you know mind versus
brain and the hardware and the software
and when I say hardware I mean like the
brain versus your mind being the
software so then misting brain meaning
the physical okay organ and then a mind
meaning the the software that the the
felt sense of being right that's good I
like to use that analogy where you've
got like you know your brain is the
hardware and then your mind is the
software but they you know you can't
have one without the other or actually
you probably have a brain but you can't
have a mind without a brain you don't to
be determined yeah and were you is this
is this when you were doing the agile
the adjunct professorship with Parsons
and and why
you so I actually like after Columbia I
want I made the decision I want to get
back into design I want to get back into
art I ended up going to Parsons with the
intention of pursuing a design degree
and and learning how to write code for
3d modeling I was really into Maya and
3d design and then at Parsons I was in a
design and technology program and still
dealing with the side effects of the
concussions and then I'd I took a
physical computing class learning how to
use an Arduino and found this tutorial
to this date it's like the coolest
tutorial on the internet it was called
how to hack toy aegs done by the front
tier nerds of NYU ITP which is where I
ended up teaching later on sweet but
like in a day I learned how to like
crack apart this little mindflex EEG toy
like Mattel had built this toy with a
single EEG sensor inside of it
and at the time I did not know what EEG
was a friend of mine was just like hey I
think you'd be interested in this any
like you want to buy this toy from me
for $40 and I was like alright sure and
he's like yeah you should just check out
this tutorial I don't know why he did
that but it you know definitely made a
huge impact on my life because honest
like Saturday morning I woke up and I
was like I gotta use project I like put
this thing on I crack it open I tap the
cereal into an Arduino and then I follow
of you know of this tutorial and with
like within a couple hours I'm looking
at my brainwaves on a screen and from
one sensor one second yeah but then I
also was like alright whatever who you
know is this real in one day you're
seeing the brainwaves and one day I'm
seeing the brainwaves and then I realize
like you know there was this one little
bar graph tied to like your focus you
know and there's like a kind of a
generic classifier that takes your raw
EEG in your band power and translate it
translates it into a focus metric and I
was like this is bogus this isn't gonna
work
but then I like you know I started
messing with it and I started to feel
the connection I was like wait a minute
like there there's something here like I
can make this bar go up I'm not sure why
it does but I feel like something in my
mind feels the connect
and then it would drop and I would know
before it was about to drop that it was
about to drop mm-hmm
cause you'd lost your focus because I'd
lost my focus and I'm like oh there is
something here so I spent like like
until six hours like from the moment I
finished the exam there the the tutorial
till like way past my bedtime I was just
like trying to move this bar graph up
and down with my mind and I'm like I
think I'm getting it I think I'm getting
it but that was like you know love at
first sight moment what else can we
control like that yeah at my mind was
just like boom this is crazy
mainly you know like there was the
selfish you know having the concussions
and being really curious about how I
could help myself you know I had been to
like neurologists and psychologists and
they were like here take some pills and
I was like nah not really I'd rather
like you know make that decision
carefully is there anything else we can
do yeah
but at the same time my grandma was
suffering from a neurodegenerative
disease called picks disease it's like a
similar to Alzheimer's was really rapid
onset dementia so it was really you know
the mind and the brain was really close
to my heart at that time and then
shortly after I discovered EEG one of my
best friends and a friend that I played
rugby with suffered a really severe neck
injury and was like paralyzed from the
neck down and luckily he made a like for
three months he was fully paralyzed from
the neck down but he made a miraculous
recovery to like basically 95% back to
where he was like walking again yep and
so you know he was he's still to this
day one of my best friends and so you
know I would go and visit him in the
hospital and like you know I was there
with him when we weren't sure if he was
ever gonna be able to move his hands
again and then I would visit him every
few weeks and and I slowly watched his
nervous system like kind of fix itself
yeah which you know he was really lucky
that he didn't sever his spinal cord he
just he just bruised it and the swelling
temporarily pinched the nerve so that
like so that essentially the messages
couldn't get through they were like the
highways were jammed right but then over
time the swelling
and he managed to get the the highway is
back you know in in his spine from the
neck down and so you know experiencing
that second hand with him you know
obviously it was like very dramatic and
and sad in the beginning but then as
watching him get through this process
and regain control of his fingers and
his legs to the point where he was like
riding a bike again yeah was incredible
and also very impactful in my interest
in not just the brain but the you know
the electrical highways that run through
your body that control all of this which
we take for granted and Phillip until
something like that happens you have the
bodies of divine vessel yeah and yeah
and for for it we only typically learn
about how grateful we are for it after
an incident so to have that ahead of
time from a mentor is so important you
you're co-founder Joel Murphy yeah you
guys are really cool I like how you guys
you know collaborate and work together
you guys ended up seeing at the Maker
Faire that what you built was really
successful and that you wanted to go and
raise a hundred thousand dollars on
Kickstarter you raise two hundred
fifteen thousand dollars on Kickstarter
you have massively surpassed your goal
and then he started producing this this
neuro revolution this very affordable
hardware that's all 3d printed and of
the course then there's the electrical
stuff as well but this also opens source
yeah which is very cool and we have you
know we have the little parts video that
Ron can bring up and show as well but
that you know the it's quite it's quite
like Legos for the yeah you're kind of
like the Lego of a of like eg of brain I
like to say that and I maybe we kind
that together
because you know because I say that now
is like you know we're basically we try
to be the Lego of neuroscience you know
we want this like building block model
where you know we you buy the kit and we
tell you how to put it together the
first time you use it but then you're
encouraged to disassemble it and plug in
different electrodes and accessories and
sensors and like build your own neuro
castle or pirate ship or you know
unicorn or whatever you whatever
whatever you want it to be it's it's
yours after you understand like the core
building blocks and how they fit
together yeah you know and I think that
is at least for for research and science
and innovation a great model you know
encouraging intuitive learning and put
it together and break it and if it
doesn't work then you put it together in
a different way and then you do that
until it works so I can download the the
CAD file of of the 3d printed it's
called the ultra cortex ultra quarter
ultra cortex is the 3d printed electric
headset yeah it's right there and then
the each one of those take it off and
then and then each one of the of the
blue there yep we call those the mech
parts mech parts those were designed by
us to fit these little grooves and allow
you to kind of twist the nodes so that
you can you know adjust for comfort and
you know kind of dial it into your own
head shot size and shape okay so each of
these nodes can be tweaked you know and
at first if you pop the thing right on
its it's not going to be comfortable
because we've got these spiky little
electrodes that are in there to get
through hair but then you know if you
really take the time and you adjust it
for your head size and shape like you
know I've had this on for the last 15
minutes and you might see some little
mark divots there but you know the work
got it so then so then the the process
of screwing in the mech part you said
yeah partner I mean that part of us yeah
start name for it I screw in the mech
part until it until the electrodes
actually get through the hair to the
actual skull yeah it's a
yeah to the gum skin cap skin to the
skin yeah yeah yeah nothing is
penetrating the skin nothing penetrates
the skin and you can still get enough of
a readout of the bio signals from and
then she can do this from anywhere from
you know one electrode to how many
maximum can you put on them on this
headset we can do up to 16 channels of
EEG you know there are much more
expensive EEG systems where you can go
up to 256 electrodes but that takes a
while to set up yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and 256 times yeah yeah yeah but this is
no this is no no deductive needed yeah
no gel needed okay and then so so I can
order that from open BCI comm but I can
also take the CAD file and print it
myself
correct as well because okay so all the
hardware designs including the
electronics we put the Gerber files on
there all all of the parts here you can
download STL's for 3d printing you know
or solid part files yeah and everything
that we design is open-source but it
just turns out that most people would
rather just buy it like you know
pre-built at least for research but the
cool thing is that you know we we put
these designs out there five years ago
you know for the electronics three years
ago for the headset and we've seen in
the last three years you know new neuro
tech companies that prototype with open
BCI electronics and open BCI hardware
it's great and then just took the
schematics reconfigured them for their
own needs maybe miniaturize things or
remove things and then you know launch
an entire company a new startup based on
our schematics and within which like you
know a lot of people in your standard
you know kind of business model would be
upset about that but that's that was our
intention like we wanted to plant these
little seeds around the world and let
these neuro plants grow into and like
you know a new industry yeah and so that
was you know that was the goal and I
think that's part of the beauty you
of open source and open hardware is just
like you know your you know you might
have a harder time raising VC because
people are like where is your IP but you
also like we've made a you know I like
to think we've made a really big impact
on the community at large and you know
now we're seeing the the BCI industry
move forward in a very healthy way where
innovation is taking place across
multiple companies in multiple research
institutions and it's not just us like
there are lots of companies that have
made really big contributions to the
space of neuro tech when you push the
edge of knowledge push it with open
source and then you open up the the
continued push and you actually inspire
other people to pursue it in an
open-source way yeah well now okay I
want to hit on a little more on the
explanation side of things so you need a
six volt double-a battery and that you
do you need that well three point seven
to six like we have a kind of a input
input voltage range okay like this one
is actually a three point seven volt
lithium ion battery that's rechargeable
behind here
okay so let's so let's take a look at
this sure okay so so on the back side is
we call this the sight on board the
sight on board and this is the the
daughter shield which we call the Daisy
this together they extend the system to
sixteen channels I only have eight
plugged in currently but if I wanted to
measure from more locations on the scalp
I could plug more electrodes in and I
could look at twice as much data at the
same time okay okay so here is where you
plug in each electrode yeah I'll show
you okay just pop this off hop that
right off so that now we're down to okay
so that enables you to add another layer
of electrodes and that's sixteen from
that as well
just eight and eight oh eight eight okay
so you have eight right now ker and that
adds another eight okay cool and then
the battery is also inside of here yeah
I'll show you this is this is kind of
the the Lego block model right yeah here
we go okay under here so this is our
base bore the sight on and then bhai
the lithium-ion battery lithium ion
battery betting that same 500 milliamp
hours okay 3.7 volts okay
that's recharge is that rich it's
recharging rechargeable wait wait let me
go so yeah so what and what do we have
noise and what do we have yeah what do
we have here so this we have you know
it's if you're familiar with Arduino
it's very similar to an Arduino with the
with the you know addition of an
accelerometer and eight bio potential
inputs so it's really an Arduino that's
purposed for measuring electrical data
from the body this is the cool this is
the 80s 1299 which is a Texas
Instruments chip and then here we've got
the MCU and then on the back we have the
radio module and an SD card slot so you
can store data locally sweet so yeah
it's designed to be somewhat portable in
the sense that you don't necessarily
need to be streaming to the computer you
could be recording to the yesterday
party so you could just walk around town
and record to the SD card and then come
home and unpack it yeah and you'll have
a lot of conversations yeah try it if
you walk down the street you won't make
it half a block without oh yes sir just
won't make a flock with no away with it
without getting a cumbersome
conversation oh yeah when I go to
conferences now I don't even need a
booth because yeah you ready to because
I just wear the headset around and
people walk up too soon yeah and then if
I want to break like if I need to sit
down and like take a chill pill
the I I have to take the headset off or
otherwise people just keep asking me
like what the heck are you I love it
what a great conversation starter so you
said this Arduino specifically for bio
signal processing yeah in a sense
interesting and then what is what is
specific about that or do we know that
makes it good for BIOS in the crossface
well it's you know the the MCU is boot
loaded with Arduino so we actually
upload the code from the Arduino IDE the
integrated or the the developer
environment okay
you know so you sue you know the
firmware that's running on this hardware
is just in our do we know
a file with our own libraries C++
libraries you know kind of compiled and
embedded in there okay but then this is
what differentiates it is is the the
analog to digital converter that's you
know really purposed for EEG
measurements so it does the translation
or it takes the analog electricity
that's coming out of your head and turns
it into zeros and ones so that a
computer can like yeah do the things
damn you take that's what that's what
helps you do the analog electrical bio
signal to zero to one data second you
can then visualize on a computer exactly
exactly
damn yeah yeah that's crazy that process
is like a black box to me and like
lately so many people about how that
actually works is that that fast fury a
transform that's later on that's live
the FFT comes when you when you've got
your waves so like okay I'll I'll start
from the ground or the kind of the
beginning we're gonna show while you
sure why don't we do that okay I'll pop
this back on I think I need to probably
restart the system okay yeah you do that
okay cool cool so now okay so now we're
gonna do on a la live demo I also want
to mention this along the way while
you're doing that so there's a couple
interesting things here one of them is
that this is a eg which is brain data
you guys also work with EMG which is
muscle data you also work with ECG which
is heart data correct so this is electro
muscle muscular grams and
electrocardiograms the electromyography
it looks like there's a problem that the
software is like crashing so she's not
wrong dude I take I take you trying to
reboot it take your time huh it looks
like there's a problem thanks thanks
and it was my the muscular is called a
electromyography my ography
electromyography for muscle and that's
what we saw at the beginning when you
saw the the child with the robotic hand
that was a that was giving muscle that
was giving a muscular correct input okay
okay oh yeah and then there's this
receiver right here too right yeah so
this is a little dongle and right now
it's giving me some trouble but I'll
figure this out this is pretty you know
pretty standard debugging okay and so
this is a USB and you can just leave it
open like this mm-hmm
without cover it's cool it's got a part
of our aesthetic hackers show the show
the guts and what's what's um oh wait
that's not the one sir okay no wonder
and then this is receiving the what you
are analyzing from here correct so and
this is the Bluetooth via bluetooth yep
and then you can also do a via Wi-Fi we
have a Wi-Fi shield that's a little bit
problematic but it does jack drastically
increase the data rates let's see if
hard time finding the Bluetooth support
that's the problem let me try this side
okay okay
of course you know the live demo is
great until you want it to yeah we had
it all yeah yeah and then we started
cracking let's try that again
okay cool cool
and we're in we're in okay cool let's
pop that on there okay and I'm gonna
join you over well the closer to you so
that I can also observe well Ron sure
will we have a good shot of the already
excellent alright signal so so this is
your software you guys also created the
software Kerr be able to visualize what
we're seeing yo okay and we've got let's
see you know do so here we have the
eight channels that are located go back
to the head plot so this is kind of a
top-down view of my head my my nose my
very triangular nose channels one two or
on my eyebrow okay so if I start
blinking my eyes you can actually see
those EMG spikes and channels one oh
that's great those yeah like okay so we
can live you blink and we get spikes see
wow yeah yeah and I can do the left eye
and the right eye oh that's so great
it's hard to do one without the other
side yeah nice oh yeah okay left eye
right eye um so you know EMG is much
easier to see you can see you know it's
it's it's a stronger signal than your
brainwaves so like if I grip my jaw but
your jaw is pretty powerful over for
yeah you can see that's big that's all
through the head on all the locations
you've got it and then the fun one guys
this is such a great way to visualize
the body you know yeah and I'm sure for
kids especially that can be disconnected
from the body in today's culture in many
ways enough to be able to put this on
and see them make a movement with their
body and see it make something happen on
a computer makes a very relatable way of
understanding that every little micro
movement
yeah let's see if I'm going to do like
so this is channel one above my left eye
she don't - above my right eye Channel
three is kind of like my left jaw and
Channel four is my right jaw those watch
this
you see how I have more the four bars
yes so what you were doing there was
literally like you were like squeezing
the muscles on your left eye and then on
your right eye and then I'm your right
John left job essentially yeah so that
you know that I think is kind of a like
a poor man's version of the future of
interaction with computers yeah I think
that like the next-gen keyboard is gonna
be or you know cursor and Mouse will be
you know highly-trained muscles on other
parts of our body where we have our
hands to still do other things
Yeah right like especially in the
context of augmented reality and virtual
reality when we want to be grabbing
things and touching things we could
theoretically have more inputs than just
our fingers we could be controlling you
know
grabbers and interact interaction
interaction you know mechanisms just
with muscles out of your head and above
our own this kind of takes us to the
Stephen Hawking yeah the ability to
communicate with the muscle movements
right so he needed it right it was the
last who's last method or technique for
communicating but I think we'll get to a
point where you know that is more
ubiquitous and used in the next
generation of wearable computers and
head-mounted displays and things like
that and potentially a greater bandwidth
of communication in this language me
vibrating my vocal cords and getting to
you maybe maybe you know language is
pretty good so like it's pretty damn
good yeah but we can we can yeah we'll
see what can so that was muscle yep okay
let me show you some brainwave let's
keep it going I don't don't lose me here
so let's go I'm gonna just kind of
reconfigure the layout okay so that's
easy layout reconfigurations yeah this
is all open source - so everything you
see here you can you can look at the
guts of the code you can build your own
widgets actually I'll show you so this
is the widget template and if you want
to design your own widget it'll take you
to a web page in our Doc's that shows
you kind of like the code needed and
then these are like template dropdowns
that are you know easy to put new
content into but let's go back here for
this sure so now I want to show you
brain also the coloration is great as
well that shows the yeah the separate
yeah yep yes so you actually sew all of
these colors here are
to the same channel and this is the FFT
so this is the frequency spectrum okay
so basically now we're gonna get to like
the science you know the the 101 where
the you know what's actually happening
here in terms of the physics and and the
electricity and things like that so K a
battery right has a pretty constant
voltage it's like like if you take a
multimeter which is a tool for measuring
voltages you can you can put it on both
sides of the battery and you can see you
know if it's double air you'll see 1.5
volts and it'll be steady if you take
the same tool and put it on the scalp
and and listen in for much much smaller
voltages that's essentially what we're
doing here we're looking for the voltage
between the potential the electric
potential between two different points
on the scalp in this case one of them is
my earlobe which essentially has nothing
going on it's just like some fatty skin
or whatever and I know what an earlobe
is and then on your brain you actually
have electricity that's being an
electrons that are being discharged from
connections and neurons in your brain
and sometimes you'll have like a
propagation or a wave of electrons that
push outward and then they splash
against the scalp okay so I like to
think of EEG as like this like we're
standing on the beach and the brain is
this vast ocean of electricity and these
waves are crashing around and splashing
and there are those like you know things
that are happening inside of the brain
like little earthquakes and storms that
are generating waves that are crashing
on the beach which is our Scouter scalp
and we're standing there and we're
watching the waves crash and then we're
trying to make inferences or we're
trying to understand what's going on in
the middle of the ocean the middle of
the ocean right so like if a giant from
just the waves crashing out of the beach
right but like you know if you if you
extrapolate that analogy you know if a
tsunami comes alright then you're like
oh man something big must have happened
or if a hurricane comes and this giant
swell takes place yeah so that's when
you know that's what kind of what we're
looking for in EEG we're looking for
these abnormalities or a secessionist
succession or
kind of series of big waves at a certain
frequency and those might be really
profound emotional states like really
good flow states or really sad me bread
or relaxed or calm or meditative so here
though like you know these are the waves
this is like essentially eight different
locations on a beach and we're looking
at the little wave splashing you know
this is in real-time
okay oh interesting so then these are
different locations on the beach got it
Rhett's
got it then that's the different
electrode locations exactly so like here
you know we've got the little locations
on the beach uni for some reason this
isn't let's see strength polarity let's
go little guys acting up there we go
so this is the intensity oh I lied
anyway long story short these are the
waves crashing on the beach and then
this graph what it's doing is it's it's
actually looking at how many waves are
splashing per second so okay it's a
frequency so it's not looking at the
strength of the waves per se it's
looking at waves per second yeah like
and what it's doing is it's breaking up
the the waves that are splashing into
different frequencies mm-hmm
and so now getting back to the brain
right if I if I close my eyes my visual
cortex which is responsible for
processing all my visual stimuli like
the shape of your face how bright that
light is all this other stuff in the
background that that plant over there
you know when my eyes are open its
processing so much information that all
the little neurons are doing different
things and they're talking to each other
and they're talking to other parts of
your brain so it looks like static it's
like
and then if you close your eyes all of a
sudden the sensory inputs are not as you
know they're not there anymore and so
what ends up happening is your brain
will return to this like default
frequency in this case it's an alpha
frequency or roughly ten Hertz on the
FFT graph so I'll give you a live demo
and the FFT graph will we'll take the
bio signals from this from the scalp and
then turn that into what you can see as
like a waves per second of exactly what
sees so show you ten Hertz it'll show
you how often exactly okay
so here like what I'll end up doing is
I'll close my eyes and then here above
ten Hertz on this FFT graph you'll see a
spike that correlates to a strength in
that frequency okay so the essentially
the fact that the waves get stronger at
that frequency that'll be reflected here
okay so let's see if I can do this and
then that also correlates to alpha it's
known as an alpha brainwave so this bar
graph should go up and then you should
see a spike here particularly in the
back of my head okay no seven and eight
because that's my visual cortex oh yeah
so if you look closer you'll actually
see the waves okay and then you'll see
the spike come up and you'll see the
graph go up okay all right
how am i doing I saw it yeah I'll go up
for a bit and then um yep yeah and then
I even read this new on it's way better
than I can but so you actually you can
see them here if you look there it's one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten per per second per second and then
ten waves per second literally like if
you if you had you know if you were
listening in there roughly ten per
second
yeah and that's why you see this little
spike here it's actually a little bit
under ten right now it's about nine okay
and then but alpha is kind of like this
whole range here yeah so and there you
go my alpha right now of all is is the
highest yeah so these other frequencies
are all happening at the same time
damn so from an FFT you can actually be
able to see exactly how much beta theta
alpha exact Gamma Delta that is going on
in the brain at a given time yep so
Delta is like zero to four Hertz data is
four to eight alpha is eight to twelve
beta is you know twelve to thirty or 14
to 30 and you can you know you can kind
of adjust these thresholds different
people you know sometimes people
classify it as like high alpha low Alvin
with more resolution but in general
these are the kind of five generic
brainwave brain frequencies or power
bands as they're referred to and then
gamma is everything that's above like
thirty Hertz one thing that's really
cool and this is people don't realize
this but it was funny they reset yeah
yeah so if I turn off this notch filter
this is a really interesting thing to
see you got to wonder what what what's
happening here if I extend this up to
120 Hertz so this giant spike here yeah
what is that that is 60 Hertz
environmental noise that is generated by
the fact that in the United States we
operate on a 60 Hertz alternating
current power grid Wow so every single
thing in this room that's powered
currently yeah is is humming or
oscillating on 60 Hertz it is for so
sixty Hertz watch if I if I touch the TV
watch what happens to that spike
should go up
maybe if I touch the power cord or the
power basically the computer yeah if
it's plugged in anything that is humming
on 60 Hertz okay yeah this is a fun one
so it's plugged in and I grab it you see
it go up a little bit yeah and then I
let go and it'll drop down so anything
that's like all this 60 Hertz
environmental noise you gotta wonder
what that's doing to us yeah it's like a
time but it's you know it's picking it
up here right these sensors can perceive
that 60 Hertz noise yeah
and we're in it all the time right yeah
versus being around
yeah trees and grass and sunlight and
yep so connecting to nature more the
story get outside kids yeah yeah more
all the stories for sure get outside and
leave your leave your iPhone behind yeah
leave your iPhone behind connect to the
thing that sustains you our planet yeah
yeah okay so that was some of the that
was some of the data around for when we
when we close our eyes with the with the
visual cortex okay
and
so we also have a yep
okay I also want to I want to we don't
have a robotic hand with us right now we
have a we have a video that shows some
of your team that was controlling the oh
yeah that's the fourth asset Ronnie yes
so some of the team was using the the
open BCI technology to control the
little walking robot oh yeah yeah and so
that kind of stuff is that's also kind
of like you've it so you get the
opportunity to visualize your bio signal
data and then you also get the
opportunity to be able to control things
that are physical in the world like the
robotic and we saw training these little
robots that your team's controlling
there yeah so walk us through that as
well sure so basically you know like we
with this software the idea is that you
can bring the data in and we've got
these little things like you know that
filter where I turned off the filter and
it's brought in that huge 60 Hertz noise
like we do some work here to get rid of
that noise so we get like a cleaner
signal right we get rid of the 60 Hertz
okay so this software you know it will
will generate like the raw data which
has all the noise if you want to look at
the noise but then also we have some
signal processing that cleans up the
data and then from there you can you
know look at this like muscle these
muscle signals that are generated here
in the software and then you can send it
out that basically route it through this
software to anywhere you want to send it
so we call this the networking widget
right here and essentially within the
networking widget you have the ability
to send over serial LSL UDP and OSC
which are four different you know kind
of networking protocols or means of
transacting data between software
hardware and then you just set up a
little you know you pick which data type
you want you could pick the time series
data the FFT data the EMG data which was
those little bar graphs when I was
blinking my eyes the band power which is
at the alpha-beta
theta Delta and then the focus widget so
I didn't show you that yet and then you
basically pick it so let's pick FFT and
then you say okay I want to send it out
over let's go oscy FFT start and now
it's we've opened up a socket and we're
streaming over OSC so we're worried to
this address here okay so now in any
software where you want to import an OSC
stream or open up the OSC socket as a
receiving end you connect to that
address and now you're pulling it into
your other software so you're so anyone
can right now be tapping into what your
is happening inside right so this you
know this software here is now like on
my computer I've opened up that OSC
socket and and with a different
application or a different software we
could be listening to the brain waves
and using that to power music or 3d
content or in the case of the robot
hands oh yeah you know so in that one we
choose the serial outbound it's kind of
like where you can control something
that's on the other side of the country
or world realm where you're sitting
right now with just your brain right
exactly so from here you can then out of
processing and then you click okay I
want to I want the filtered data and I
want to send it via this protocol there
and then you set up a stream you send it
out so in the case of the robot hand we
were looking at the EMG actually from
the head and we were mapping the EMG
signals from the head to the actuation
of the robot arm which was powered by an
Arduino and some other electronics so
these are all examples of things that
you can do you know you could send it to
unity for doing 3d content you could
send it to max/msp for doing audio
there's a whole suite of open-source
biosensing software applications for
doing like machine learning and
classification for building like
emotional profiles and things like that
yeah and this you know the whole idea
with open BCI is just to make the
acquisition and networking process as
easy as possible yeah where do you where
do you see then the most use of open BCI
right now is it is it people observing
their bio signals on your software from
wearing it is it them all like our
decent amount of people also trying to
control physical objects with like we
saw there yep yeah I mean it's at this
point you know the majority of open BCI
users are in the research realm so
they're so they're you know they're
collecting data and you know
contextualized data they're running
experiments and they're looking at EEG
or brain data in the context of
something so sleep research or attention
deficit disorder or you know the like
what else can you know that there are
people who are working with it for
prosthetics kind of like the controlling
the robot arm so you could tap into you
know
residual muscle data of the forearm or
the bicep and then use it to power
prosthetics so long story short people
are using an open BCI for like so many
different things and it's it's actually
hard for us to keep track of like yeah
what our market actually is because we
have students that are using it to like
learn what what neuroscience is and you
know what EEG signals look like kind of
like what I was showing you for the
first time and then we have like the top
consumer technology companies in the
world like I won't name names but a lot
of them most of them have purchased open
BCI gear and are probably using it for
rnd for next generation product design
which is an interesting topic that maybe
we should touch on which is what yeah
you know you know where are we headed
like what is the future of NCI and and
you know what do we have to look forward
to and what do we have to be you know
potentially afraid of you know and what
should we you know we mentioned it in
the beginning of the conversation like
what what should we design around what
do you know what what little dystopian
dystopian black interior scenario should
we be like yeah not that yeah and let's
make sure that like the river splits
there and and we're on that path a good
path yeah so so what is that then what
is
future the the two things that scare me
most about the the potential and the
implication you know the the you know
what BCI could do are its impact on
technology addiction and also social
stratification yeah so I think you know
you know health is another ethical
concern you know are these things safe
but I mean I think technology addiction
falls into that but you know I really
don't think that we're gonna be
invasively
implanting electrodes anytime soon you
know like Elon Musk talks about neural
link and you know there are other
companies that are looking to fast-track
putting sensors into the brain but I
think that we've barely tapped into the
potential of non-invasive brain brain
computer interfacing and non-invasive
BCI but by non-invasive I mean like
outside of the skin outside of the skull
yeah is I believe going to become a
ubiquitous technology and not just EEG
but biosensing in general basically like
not not necessarily understanding the
brain but the mind getting back to the
beginning of the conversation it's like
we don't really care about the brain we
care about the software inside of the
brain we care about the the processes
and understanding what makes you who you
are which is like your cognition your
thoughts your emotions you know that's
like that's what matters really so maybe
we should be called open MCI mind
computer interface but too late now
anyway but like you know getting back to
your question like you know the two
things I really am concerned about our
technology addiction and social
stratification in mind control mind
control yeah and you know and so in it
to a degree that is technology at
technology addiction right like we even
now technology and applications on your
phone are so addictive that they're
controlling us that they're controlling
us you know they're capturing our
attention and they're taking us away
from you know other meaningful endeavors
exactly an interactions with people you
know like social media is this like
social band aid where we get this like
immediate kind of fix like oh people
like me people
care about me but you know in doing that
it's taking your time away from
investing in real relationships where
like if you were in trouble or if you
were you know if you needed emotional
support you can call up your best friend
and be like hey man we got to hang out
because I got to talk to you yeah you
know I was like and I think people are
losing that to a certain degree relying
on like casting this wide social net
yeah anyway that's that's a whole nother
let's let's hit let's hit on this so you
were here at the Augmented World Expo
yeah and you were seeing a lot of HMDs
head mountain displace like the like the
holo lenses and stuff yeah and so you
see a future also where brain computer
interfaces are intertwined at these head
mounted displays I do I think that the
future of computation will feature the
combination of art of men in reality so
essentially displays that are overlaid
on top of our real world environment
artificial intelligence so machine
learning and algorithms that are
understanding and optimizing your
experience in the background and then
brain computer interfacing or more you
know kind of more broadly multimodal
mind computer interfacing so I tracking
measuring your heart rate your heart
rate variability looking at your brain
data but building this complex
physiological representation of you
right so you know that information is
what's going to be fed into computers
and to the a the machine learning and
the art of the AI algorithms that are
optimizing and and altering your
experience that you perceive through a
screen in front of your face and audio
that's on your ears at all times you
know and that and that will be at the
core of the future of computers and you
know I + AI + AR exactly you know in a
art you know pick whatever acronym you
don't want X are AR but like we will
reach a point where digital content is
always not just on a little screen in
our hand but like overlaid into the real
and ideally we'll have the ability to
opt out and like have your normal
conversations yeah yeah yeah I yeah
ideally it's like it's like we can't
just you know force indigenous people on
the planet Yeah right yeah yeah yeah I
mean like it will happen but I do think
that you know a lot of people will
choose to tap in a lot of people choose
to tap in yeah and at that point lived
there even right all the time all the
time yeah like and at that point who is
ultimately in control over the content
the controllers of the substrate right
that you'd go into right and so this is
one of my you know one of the things
that we really I believe we really need
to start thinking about critically which
is that little AI agent in the
background that's receiving all of your
biological information in the context of
what you're looking at where you are
what you're touching in the real world
or in the virtual world you know that is
extremely valuable and vulnerable data
and Google and Baidu and $0.10 Alibaba
Facebook and Apple Amazon Microsoft are
all racing as fast as they can to try
and create the monopoly that that houses
that data that the operating system of
the mind right when the the the human
mind becomes this core data set in a
computer which we're trending towards
for sure yes who owns that mind you or
the people who built the tool to house
it right and I think that this is like
you know this is the single greatest
question that drives me as an
entrepreneur which is like you know how
do we stake out that future so that user
agency like you as the user in this
system are the primary agent in control
of the priorities of that system like
this system is not being prioritized to
send you the best ads that are most
likely to do for you to click on and
look over lay it on the wall and be like
oh that's great you know but like how do
you like control this you know this this
this AI agent in the background and make
sure that the priorities are aligned
with you as an individual
that's the big question of our time it's
a massive question of our time yeah and
yeah this century is going to be about
that a lot of this century is going to
be about that yeah so I'm really glad
that you're passionate about teaching
about the importance of that and as you
build out the democratization of the
technology hopefully it also gets young
people like we saw at the very beginning
excited about talking more about these
pressing questions instead of it just
happening to them but rather they get a
stake because they actually understand
how it's all working they get a stake in
the global conversation about how to
prevent the oops scenarios yeah when we
have such ancient minds and bodies that
are playing with godlike technologies
that's where we have the issues of
civilizations collapsing right so we do
not want to repeat that again as we move
into the future well what are some of
the what are some of the other things
that you think we may have did we miss
stuff that you think super important to
mention about open BC I so I mean kind
of an extension of the topic we're just
on in terms of integration with HMDs and
AR this summer we're gonna be you know
it's a challenging endeavor that we're
embarking on but we're trying we're
going we're gonna create a an add-on for
a AR and VR which will have integrated
sensors and the goal is to basically
build this rich multi motor multimodal
sensor fusion add-on for VR yeah and
then have that supported by a kind of a
basic 3d SDK and probably in unity or
unreal and then provide this to the
world and just say like okay so I'm
wearing my VR headset and instead of me
needing to to move around the the
joysticks and stuff I'm literally just
thinking to move forward stuff like that
I think it'll be a combination of the
two yeah you know
you know like oh the hand gestures and
haptic gloves and things like that are
gonna be critical for AR and VR yes
but the you know building an sdk for the
OS of the mind and extend and putting
that in the hands of as many people as
possible I think is one of the you know
I don't know if this is the correct
solution but I know it is in my mind
it's it's a step in the right direction
is like you know if we can take the
innovation and move it out of the
proverbial ivory tower and just put it
into the hands of everyone then it then
like you know you know when if and when
Facebook or whoever creates this kind of
master tool that has you know direct
access to your mind you know you know I
think it's better that that technology
is owned by everyone and then that
innovation is taking place in many
different places at the same time as
opposed to in like you know the three
you know the highest the you know
highest budget companies in the world
you know and that's part of the reason
we're doing it is like hey look let's
just put this out there and let everyone
have access to it so that people
understand it they understand the risks
they understand the benefits and like
you know the IP is is not isolated and
owned by a single company so it's a
wisdom race that we're going through and
if you can get the human OS of the mind
open sourced through it like an SDK out
potentially you can inspire more of the
democratization the conversation that we
need to stake out the error scenarios
collectively and also have a like an
occlusive stake holding in our future
where everyone is interdependently
interconnected and intertwined with the
stakes that we hold within the
organizations that we're moving in that
direction from the triangle to the
circle we need to move there faster to
get the wisdom race successfully I like
that yeah angles it's a circle yeah yeah
the meat of the we yeah yeah Conor this
isn't such a good episode I want to hit
a couple quick questions on the way out
Ron isn't a big fan of this one but I
like asking it what what happens
pre-birth and post-death pre-birth
and post-death want one
so pre-birth you know we are yeah I
guess like you know from the moment that
you become a little you know nugget in
your mom's belly right your you know
your heart starts beating your brain
starts you know the gears the clockwork
starts ticking and you know you're alive
you know especially later in the
pregnancy where do you think we come
from before that before that yeah that's
a good one you know we're just we're
just energy you know conservation we're
just we're just energy come you know we
it's not like we flicker out of nothing
we you know we it's it's yeah that's a
tough question
on the other eye I do like to think that
there is something beyond death
my grandpa actually just passed away
last week which was it was it was a
tough experience but I also it was
definitely his time yeah grandpa Jim
James leader loved him he was a great
grandfather but he was the husband of my
grandma who I was talking about earlier
in the episode who passed away from the
the neurodegenerative disease so he had
a rather tragic
you know last 10 years of his life
because shortly after my grandma passed
away within the week afterwards he had a
stroke and you know that was kind of the
beginning of the end for him it was a
series of like he had another stroke not
too long after that you know so I like
to think that they're now back together
again you know somewhere whether it's
energy flowing through you know
the Stars or whatever I like to think
that now they've been reunited but you
know I don't think death is the end I
think it's just a gateway to the next
chapter to maybe even other beginning
potentially yeah yeah what do you think
we're alone in the cosmos no definitely
not 100% no and then do you think we're
in a simulation possibly I mean I
honestly think that we are have you ever
looked at like the the the largest scale
of galaxies and and Laniakea it's like
the is the the spine of galaxy
formations that were inside of and we
have this picture that's slightly bigger
than Laniakea look it up but like it
looks like at the at the largest scale
neurons yeah bad brain I like to think
that we're this tiny little speck inside
of some other organisms brain and that
somewhere in my brain and in your brain
exists the same complexity of like a
universe yeah out of a universe inside
of universe fractals all the way up and
down down and I like to think that like
people think that the human like mind
can be reverse engineered and I am like
firmly like the human brain
maybe but like my consciousness
infinitely complex same as yours and I
think that there's like little universes
inside of us that can spark to life and
influence and create a ripple effect all
the way through my mind and like you
know this is just smile like fantastic a
view of the complexity of the universe
and all the other universes that are
within it and outside of it what do you
thinks the most beautiful thing in the
world the most beautiful thing in the
world
my girlfriend yeah yeah I had to say
that the most beautiful thing in the
world I see
it's a good one
I mean I think it's got to be the human
mind it's it's you know and I say the
mind very distinctly from you know
separate from the human brain because
it's infinitely complex and yeah it's
it's ooh I don't think we'll ever fully
understand it and that makes it
beautiful that and
the vastness of the universe so it's a
it's a hard you know but I like to you
know this is more personal so it's uh I
picked that and I don't mean my mind and
my mind is not most people I think just
mean like the human mind is a beautiful
thing
so cards it's such a great episode thank
you so much for coming on huge thank you
to everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it love to hear your thoughts
in the comments below on the episode we
would love for you to check out the
links also to open BCI dot-com also
their Twitter definitely get talking to
more people get playing with the style
of technology for your friends your
families co-workers people online on
social media get talking more about the
democratization of brain computer
interfaces go and start actually playing
with them yourself think about all the
great aspects of research that we can do
with these so get playing with the Legos
of neuroscience yes and also support the
artists entrepreneurs the organizations
around the world that you believe in
support simulation our links are below
help us grow and pause prosper you shout
out to Ron Vargas for producing a never
ending thank you Ron and go and build
the future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world thank you so much for
tuning in and we will see you soon peace
[Music]
[Music]
you